so
um
now
this is
the core teaching of the mystic
traditions
still the noisy mind
and recognize your union
with perfection
with freedom
um
if you are watching
in seeking to heal your confusion
to deepen your awakening enlightenment
union with freedom and perfection that
you already are
ask yourself the simple question
how many minutes per day
do i consciously still
my noisy mind
so
um
crap
i just realized you're hanging out with
a multi-hundred-year-old
tree
and a timeless deafening silence
small context
sockman nate zarin
mchigh and i
met about three or so
years ago in san francisco
the bay area and
our first conversation
was episode 113 on the
show which we're now at 7 54
for our second episode together which i
do think is the longest
chunk of time between the same guest
appearing on the show
which is pretty cool
and the first time that we talked
we were both in a
from what i understand seeking
and then the second time that we're
now talking we have both found
and it's deepening but we now
have communed with that diamond that was
already around our necks
and so
i'm jacked for the convo
[Laughter]
the first combo we had i didn't even
know what your show was about
the second combo we have it's about
nothing
[Applause]
sockman's metaphysical
name is sockman
his birth name is nate zarin and his
awakening music rap name is
mc high is that right
don't know man
sounds pretty good too
he's been deploying a lot of good
awakening music
but i've really enjoyed a lot
and his analogy of the sock
and repping that with his name is really
good for
metaphysical insight
could you explain it for us
even the beginning of the interview was
a sock
recording silence
it's the inverting quality of the
simultaneous
fullness and emptiness infused
in this present display
and it feels like on a personality layer
i'm just the accumulation of all socks
like if you're a sock man you know who
you are
hoodie beauty you're socked out but
it's just what it is
[Music]
okay so the sock
for most of the
individuations in this creation is
jutted outward
and when you
undergo the process of reversing
the sock
okay so
for most of
the individuations in the creation
this is your perception
jutting out towards objects and
experiences and relationships and
substances
and trying to seek material possessions
and what awakening or enlightenment
is in many ways
is it's taking this
and
reversing that
very perspective
that you were you were jutting out your
your your vision
out here and now what you've done is
you've in a sense
reversed that
to become aware of your awareness aware
of your being
aware of your source
and then the sock disappears
where you are the sock
we've already gotten anders threw up the
sock emoji already
eve throwing up the soccer bunch you're
starting a trend i love it it's become
one of my favorite emoji sets also
i love it
i love it
what's the best way to visualize this
so
oh like
like this
it's the non-dual object
i've dissolved many times just turning a
sock inside out
yes using
language
it's like
it's like taking yourself looking at a
tennis ball or a pen
or whatever you have and rather than
looking at the object
you become aware of the awareness and
then you become aware of the source of
the awareness
and then you kind of just like pop into
nothingness like reverse all of creation
back into nothingness
and then you pop all of creation back
out to
all of these individuated agents that
are
observing creation that all are one
intelligence
uh play with itself in this universe
and so the basically the faster that you
can pop
consciously with your different lenses
pop into nothingness pop into
everythingness pop into
the redwood tree behind you pop into
your
glass of water pop back to nothingness
pop to everythingness and just
be able to just do that
do you feel like that's sort of one of
the last
stages of awakening is the ability to
navigate
all of that
i feel like there's no foundation for
authority
of stages
in in my personal experience with the
story that i've kept
i i feel the same way that you do where
it's like
you invert the sock like i can see
everything so it's not me because i'm
the observer observing it
and then you realize that one last
sphere of observer
completely blends in with the rest of
the field so you're simultaneously the
sock
and there's no sock but
it doesn't seem like there's a stair
step
yeah seems like the stair step is the
the rainbow
in the levels of the dream
where do we go from there man it's this
is the biggest
conversation sort of happening in
awakening slash enlightenment circles is
that
there's no path it's just already free
perfection
there's no path and then simultaneously
when somebody's like i'm suffering what
do i do and you're like there is no path
you're perfect and free
and so your response to them if you can
have multiple lenses
which personally from what i understand
the best way to navigate is to have
these different lenses to help people
because that's you
asking for help in the stream and so in
the
conversation it would be you know still
the noisy mind
practice using your breath your
respiration
to just recognize that that's a thought
cloud
that's either in the past or it's in the
future and that it's making you
depressed or anxious
and to just still the noisy mind
repeatedly using the breath
and become aware of even being and aware
of
awareness itself and relax more and more
into that and then recognize that you
are what actually
created the awareness in beingness and
reality
so to move your identity more and more
from
being a person to being the source of
creation
to love and accept yourself radically
and fully exactly as you are
right integrating
seeing clearly the groundless ground and
the tracelessness of
the pathless path which you talk about
is
is indivisible from having
a strong belief that there never was a
path
if it's not directly experienced then
there's no
dissipation and we experience death
and so as atlas is atlas and saves the
world
there's there's no attachment of the the
story
of the freedom because if there was
attachment of the story of the freedom
would perpetuate
the interdependent negativity exactly
i will only be happy when the
sustainable development goals are met
that's a recipe for disaster that's a
recipe for attachment
my nature is happiness
and peace and perfection and freedom
every
single heartbeat
and in this north star position in a
very
non-attached way the calling in the
north star position
is to meet the basic needs of people on
the planet
is to maximize planetary awakening
this is where buddha and atlas merge
into one
this is what the bodhisattva is
actually just to take a moment to deepen
the
amount of gratitude that
radical love
and acceptance
for you and i
and for this entire creation exactly as
it is
and for
ineffable gratitude
for the force
behind
sockman and atlas being so
driven to
figure it out
you i find myself here what is the point
of this who am i
what is i what is me what are we doing
here
to the point of uniting with the answer
embodied realized
and then being able to radiate like the
sun
with love and light and wisdom and grace
and peace and joy
and service pure service
and so i'm really grateful that this is
actually a really
interesting example
of
a multiple year
dedication and then piercing the veilus
fail
and then getting to talk about it
afterwards
the quality never changed so there's
really
nothing to talk about and as long as
that feels true to your soul
the tracelessness will take you all the
way because there's no
moral equivalent to wrap you
in the dual spinning
but if i'm like i want to be silent for
the rest of my life like a tree and i
force it
and it's not doing anybody any good
i think this is what you said yes
the tracelessness will take you all the
way
something that i've learned from you
along this story
was the simultaneity of being in touch
with the tracelessness while
weaving the tapestry
okay
to clarify
when you reference tracelessness
there was never anybody sitting on that
bench there you go
uh
wow
wow the recognition of nothingness
actually deepens when tracelessness
is further deepened itself as well
this pace of conversation helps not only
me
but i'm sure everybody else to
continuously recognize on more
immediate layers so the silence
cultivates the intellectual latticework
instead of the intellectual latticework
cultivating the angle of the silence
that we abide at
and this is the shift that
this community is passing over right now
so
ah
so
an asterisk that i would add
to
abiding in silence
is that if when you're abiding in
silence
if you're not consciously
becoming more of an adept to
see the difference between
the noisy mind of thought clouds versus
the pure
bare empty aware beingness
then you're perpetuating
long spaces of time
where you just let your noisy mind go
bonkers
so the unfreezing of your will
and choice
from your robotic
algorithms which is what
happened for me and many others
that awaken
is that you slowly redirect your
attention
towards the pure bare
empty sky of awareness rather than
the noisy mind clouds of
thoughts and emotions and beliefs and
needing to
force your perspective into everything
and so while sockman
what he says is imperative
it's paramount it's the cultivation
of the intention as well with the
silence
and the space
just like the i am teachings if you fall
into a pattern of rigidity
of directing yourself over and over stay
silent don't think
your mind can't stay in your mind
and so it's recognizing the inevitable
enough
[Laughter]
the identity of self-liberation as soon
as it arises
we do practice this rigidity to gain
recognition
and after recognition rigidity falls
away
what is the intention behind the
affirmations
of you are infinity your
nature is infinite possibilities
because that
that can create and has created a knee
in my story
rigid beliefs that
create a boundary from direct
recognition
will you explain how it's done that
if i believe it is nothingness
or i am infinity then
that conceptual wall
[Music]
clouds up the void of ineffability
how does it cloud
because it it inhibits or
it blocks the clear view of
tracelessness
if i'm defaulting on a conceptual flat
insight i am emptiness i am infinity
yes and it plays into the statement
right here is
after recognition the rigidity falls
away
and i would add a small asterisk to the
section over there as well that even
after recognition
that you'll still have for example
it's not like sockman lives in perpetual
tracelessness
and then ends up having a
conversation with somebody
because here's the thing you're gonna
have a conversation with somebody
and when you have a conversation with
somebody what's going to happen
is that even though you know there's
tracelessness
what's going to happen is that there are
still going to be
catalysts and there are still going to
be distortions
that are indicated for you
so if you bathe in perpetual
tracelessness
you will completely ignore
the catalysts that are trying to
indicate to you
that you still have purification work to
do
to not be
coming from a place of your conditioning
so you could say that the rigidity of
no mind enables you to
gain recognition of ineffable perfect
freedom that you
already are traceless infinite
and after recognition
the vast majority of the rigidity falls
away
and you become liberated to use
any of these lenses any time
but specifically the rigidity
with vigilance on
every single frame as you do the
tapestry weaving
is important because
you'll notice that
there will still be a slight nuanced
subtle difference between when you're
coming from your conditioning versus
when you're coming from
source i am
this is what is the most
awakened subtle nuance
of spirituality that
i've recently been introduced to
by bentino massaro and their team in the
no limit society
and it's
incredible because it's like the navy
seals
of spirituality
but it's up to your unique expression
of this traceless infinitude
if you will
care about this
perpetual purification away from
conditioning
and to coming only from
the highest expression of god
serving itself in its own
one intelligence playing
or if you'll come from a kink or a twist
or a distortion in your conditioning
which still serves the creation
but you will gain more vigilance
with discerning between those
and the choice will be yours up until
the point when there is no choice
because then the only choice that's left
is to come from source
i am period
for every single frame period
but then the purifications will get even
more subtle
and even more nuanced in even more
highest
echelons of navy seals
and that's the game
from what i understand
how did that resonate sock man
just in our brain man
that resonated
in this highly concentrated to full
purity
if it feels natural dissolution is all
that
that is necessary tracelessness is all
that is necessary
and if the dream layers are act are
activated and engaged
with creating effects on the world
whichever way that's also necessary
this sounds like
what you just said is that correct
tracelessness is all that is necessary
for pure tapestry
weaving
why not
perfect
the more empty you are of your
conditioning
of your psychology of your
ego of your onion layers
of your identification with personhood
the more empty you become
the more you're able to
hold space for
the creation to awaken
and to do it from a place of purity
the creation awakening being the
tapestry weaving
you're able to do it from a place of
purity because you're coming from a
place of tracelessness
versus coming from a place
of conditioning twist distortion ego
onion layer
damn
so as we sat
for that minute or so in silence
after the last banner appeared
the understanding of tracelessness is
all that is necessary for pure tapestry
weaving
deepened because we sat in silence
because we abided in tracelessness
it deepened so the very silence
further cultivated the very lattice work
that enables
the deepening of the profound
recognitions
of the true nature
i would add another asterisk
by the way see this little adding of an
asterisk
only came from abiding in silence for
another minute
it's coming from emptiness right
there's no there's no using your mind to
think of the next thing to say
that's one of the biggest things i've
learned from rapping is you need to not
think to have something to think about
taking that step back is where it
happens
also this this gem of the non-duality
community
we can listen to each other talk and
the dream of the awareness display
points towards the all-pervasive essence
it's just our mind it's really amazing
thank you man thank you
i highly encourage our audience
to follow sockman
his
instagram and spotify
links will be below in the bio
he is very much a young master of
awakening and is weaving it into
music and
more and i learn
all the time when i talk to him
the little asterisk that was coming
through
was that in this tracelessness
is all that is necessary for pure
tapestry weaving
the tiny asterisk would be that
if the expression of
infinity that you are
if the traceless firework that you are
is to abide in tracelessness in
a mountain cave away from all humans
then that's your expression
but you can tell that that
is not the bodhisattva
atlas tantric sahaja samadhi
weaving of the profound awakening
realizations
into the civilizational architectures
and protocols
and enabling further
planetary awakening it is in its own
way energetically
so the tiny little asterisk would be is
the main
test
to be traceless in a
mountain cave or is the main test to be
traceless
in the middle of manhattan
right whatever is happening is happening
and so being the bodhisattva or the
atlas with no attachment to the result
is just as traceless as sitting in a
cave
engaging in the world
not seeing the tracelessness of it and
assuming that there's
concreteness in it traps one
in the extreme circling of the dualities
the interdependence between the good and
evil forces
and so
we're talking to ourselves man it's
really a beautiful thing to
be a part of yes
talking to myself in a dream
and sockman says it so well
that if you don't know
this is one intelligence at play with
itself in a dream
you will get stuck in the perpetual
cycle
of duality and of maya
and qualities that you identify yourself
with will dissipate
yeah because now instead of being one
intelligence playing with itself in a
dream
now instead you've become a person with
a career and with
a a preference for material possessions
to try and prove your worth to other
people to get validated by them
you really start seeing the misery
i hang out with the statue
she's she's reading the dharma
you see in the book right there it says
the three jewels of buddhism
[Laughter]
buddha dharma sangha just flip between
the vedic
actually the statue reminds me of the
tree behind you as well
the tree is going through a
faster cycle of impermanence
because of the photosynthetic
quality with the oxygenation
of the planet's atmosphere to enable us
to
be this one intelligence at play with
itself in a dream
so the statue has a
somewhat similar cadence to it because
it does not have a mind
that is hella noisy and toiling it
around endlessly
but at the same time it's not creating
oxygenation
you
so
[Laughter]
you want to try something out and go one
brain
in a dream
all right let's uh
let's talk to ourselves i'll say one
word you say one word i'll say one word
[ __ ] yeah okay the
story of our
unified theory
is that which
inexhaustibly purifies
dreams
can we say period and start a new
sentence
i am
period
[Laughter]
that one was so good
our
reality is
one unchanging
source
okay
love
is the
truth
shhh
can we deepen the challenge of the
activity
by also turning it into
music can we add a musical
rhythm as we go
okay hmm
[Music]
i
[Laughter]
laughed
[Music]
[Laughter]
time
conceptual located star cluster going
far
making an atlas going bar for bar
the ineffable perfection already inside
you you
fool all you gotta do is turn inward
reverse that sock
inside out get to the very source of
your ineffable creation
that you're exploring
that you're exploring it's a piece of
paper that never was torn
it's all you and nothing is formed
there's nothing you could ever really
learn
nectar man nectar
that's such a good word for it
the best way to describe the i
am god
the witness the observer the
all-inclusive awareness the being
presence
nectar
nectar the
same way that the bees
collect nectar and pollen from the
lavender plant is the same way that
humans collect the nectar
from the planet the civilization
the big bang
you and i think that song is there to
ever sing
searching lyrics
i took a note from a bit ago that i'd
like to
share as well because
sockman is a
rapper musician artist
he brought this up earlier
the very nature
of creativity
is that you have to get out of your own
way
you see all of the examples with
freestyle rappers
it's the most common one
the moment that they start having these
self-referential thoughts
the freestyle disappears
dissolving the why
the why that takes you all away
these what where when why who questions
are the
the traceless essence which fades out of
the verbal
located spectrum
and that's why if you dig far enough
into the
into questions like these who am i
what is i what is me
who what when where how why
you get to tracelessness
then you get out of your way get all of
the conditioning
and the ego out of the way
and let the creative flow to just
divinely channel through
the entire creation is one big freestyle
that was uh the first sock man
that's where it came from initially so i
was freestyling and i was
rapping about rapping or rapping about
existing
it's like well it's like a sock
it's a style man
ugh
amanda popped in we love you
highly recommend checking out the anata
i am estranged loop
by amanda
i
[Music]
that piece of art
[Music]
music kaleidoscopic
beauty is
a masterpiece
for awakening
it really got me to deepen
the illusion of the eye
the intoxicative illusion of the eye
i would say it even got me to pop
in many ways from self capital s
to no self from atman to anatman
[Laughter]
so
recap the tracelessness
will take you all the way
all the way to nowhere
and then from that sourceful
emptiness freestyle
create in service
to the creation
rather than serving the distortion
simultaneity of tracelessness plus
tapestry weaving
silence cultivates the intellectual
lattice work
the enabling of profound recognitions
the people that i've been with that have
been some of the most pure
empty mirrors
in service to the creation have been the
most
jedi-like in creating the silent
containers that enable the profound
recognitions
so that's another great thing for the
tracelessness
is to hold that space for the creation
to awaken
practice rigidity to re to gain
recognition
after recognition rigidity falls away
yet the purification continues
tracelessness is all that is necessary
for pure tapestry weaving
one intelligence playing with itself in
a dream
get out of your own way for rap
creativity
the more that you take yourself away
from your distorted
person conditioning towards coming from
the empty sourcefulness is exactly what
enables
you to
rap be creative freestyle
do art do music do
entrepreneurship and the more that you
come from
a distorted
person conditioning the more you're in
your own way
and you're a person instead of being a
vessel
for source god i am-ness
the entire creation is one big freestyle
cool
all right
how do you feel about
i was gonna say i was gonna say rapping
but i figured you were gonna
not do the wrap but the rap response
some people just prefer to stream it
this has been an interesting part of our
relationship also
is the
perpetuation of continued
sharing of the path of awakening
versus the
no sharing of the path of awakening
truth is a pathless land
for a good sock mirror man
um so sock man is
another way of saying infinite bra
to an extent yeah it's the same kind of
thing
it's just i'm a socket he's a bra
i love that
but the sock dies and the bread dies
i like the idea of when people
taste glimpse and then embody
tracelessness to call them sockman
they've tasted the reversing of creation
to nothingness
audience question do we live in a
simulation since we are in a dream
sock man do you distinguish at all in
the difference between a simulation or a
dream
[Laughter]
i had an interesting dream about a
simulation
which was a universe that sprouted a
civilization of humans
there was this interesting dream though
where um
just like with the audio file if you
copy two audio files and you invert the
phase of one
it creates silence on both sides we went
into the simulation
in the dream and headsets were created
that completely mirrored your brain
waves
and liberated everybody into two-fold
emptiness
it was all the dream
shout out
we'll put the link in the bio below to
anata i am a strange look by amanda
rizzo as well
you know what you just said is awesome
because
it's like the creation itself is the
song in the eternal symphony and then
the
the nothingness is like what you
described with taking the track and
inverting it and putting it
on top and having that silence
huh
question for you from rob where does the
motivation to make music come from
does the meat suit do it and you just
watch it unfold
watching the motivation dissolve
has been a big part of the story
just being very depressed and then
seeing the groundless ground
and seeing that there's nothing to do
and nothing to learn
nowhere to go and so
the music has created itself since the
sock man project
and it would be it would take effort to
shut my mind off
and be like rigid about not thinking of
bars
oops
[Music]
[Music]
all right
that's a wrap
it's a nice freestyle man good rap
this conversation was a microcosm
freestyle of what the civilization and
universe are doing macrocosmically
just surrender to the infinite
unfolding
it was all a dream blank characteristic
[Laughter]
television
all right thanks everyone for tuning in
infinite adoration thank you thank you
check out the links in the bio below to
sock man's
instagram it's awesome posts a lot of
good content on there also his
spotify for his music and you can find
our homie
amanda rizzo's another strange loop down
there as well
and if the convo brought you value
would love for you to give it a like
helps the algo subscribe if you haven't
to the channel
give us a comment below with your
thoughts we'd love to hear from you
and share the video with people that you
feel like
it would bring value to
all righty
i look forward to our next inception bro
me too me too all right i'm gonna
end the broadcast and we'll stay in the
studio and chat for a moment
hmm